hey everybody its Jesse this stream I'm
having troubles with with my streaming
so that's why I was delayed I'm thinking
this this is probably a pretty bad
stream so let me know in the live chat
what it's like so I'm I'm streaming from
home today and my connection my upload
connection is not nearly as fast as it
is like a thing with my upload speed at
work is like I don't know like 25 times
faster than what I have at home so I'm
not seeing anything in the live chat
right now let me see if anybody's
actually in here oh okay
I see a couple people my analytics must
be lagging a little bit because it said
nobody was in here all right so that's
that's good the the control room and
YouTube is just giving me all kinds of
read error messages here so I kept
thinking this wasn't going to work so
luckily because I kind of suspected that
my mics quality my stream might not be
as high as normal I've decided to just
tackle the load balancing issue that
we've been talking about you know for I
don't at least a week I think maybe
you've been I've been mentioning it so I
figure that'll be easier to see then a
lot of code so it'll be mostly done in
the terminal I can make just kind of
blow it up really big and you really
only have to look at me doing one
command at a time and actually not even
in the terminal there's a lot of stuff
will just be done right in the browser
so that should be easier even if the
quality's a little bit lower
oh I didn't even notice those oom dit
was Sebastian just mentioned in the live
chat it's really zoom then I I just
checked to see what my screen looks like
to you all and it does look really
zoomed what is going on haha Wow
all right let me let me fix this because
it should not be that it shouldn't be
that small
let's see
let me try let me try switching to
another display and see how that looks
for you it looks like it's not even it's
not letting me switch
you
all right so let me um
I'm actually let me take a second and
I'm gonna restart this stream so it
might go down for a second I'm gonna
start right back up again
I just need to know a few minutes ago it
was it was displaying fine and then I
just switched from one of my displays to
another and then now it now I can't
switch back I can't change anything so I
just want to restart I'm using OBS to
stream I just want to restart it quickly
and and see if that makes a difference
hopefully I've never actually stopped
and restarted a stream before so
hopefully this just picks up right in
the same event and it doesn't mess
everything up
otherwise I'd hate to have to start a
new event but I'll get it started sorry
for the delay
okay I think I'm back and I'm actually
not getting the errors anymore on my
stream so let me know if you can hear me
if you can see anything
let go which is working the video so can
anybody hear me now but not see the
video or can you not hear me at all I
mean I'm going to type in the chat too
okay so looks like so you can hear
there's maybe like a minute delay
between what I'm doing and what you all
see so so some people have video but no
audio and some people said they have
audio no video all right it looks like
it's it is working all right so yeah the
there might be some some buffering or
some weird stuff going on that's just
because my internet connection I
actually have the best connection that I
can possibly buy for my location it is
really sad I think my my max
download speed is like 25 megabits per
second and maybe I have like five for
upload so it's not great
at least I mean it's okay for doing
pretty most of what I need to do for my
work but when it comes to live streaming
it's not not good so sorry for all that
that mess I really should have just
scheduled the event to start later a
half hour later and then save you all
the trouble of uh of watching me try to
fix it all but at least now I have it
set up so I should be able to stream
from my laptop from home now if I need
to so it looks like Paul and live chat
says he only gets 10 download one upload
ok so that's I feel a little bit better
now
it's actually crazy I think I pay like
like eighty or ninety dollars a month
for the twenty five upload and I think
it's five download but I really can't
ever consistently get over like three
four download my upload usually rates it
like I don't know maybe eighteen at the
highest so you know that works you never
really get as much as they tell you
you're gonna get
oh man hums hums as for downloading one
upload sorry about that
oh I'm hoping you know like Google or
Facebook or somebody will come through
with one of their their plans to beam
internet from planes or balloons or
something or isn't uh doesn't Elon Musk
want to do it from satellites or
something so I'm hoping that works out
one day and we can all get a good
internet and there won't be a monopoly
anymore from from the cable companies so
but until that time we have to deal with
with this Internet so yeah
shree shree con sorry if I'm
mispronouncing the name it looks like
Sri Kampf says the 4G is faster than the
home network that's how my network used
to be and when I realized it when I did
speed tests on my 4G and on my home
network and I realized my 4G was faster
that was like the last straw and then I
I called and just said what's the
fastest I can get and that was it so now
now I had a faster it just seemed crazy
to me that I'm a web developer and I I
would have internet that was slower than
then 4G so all right so enough about the
Internet let's uh let's get get to work
wow this must be a popular topic so I
posted on Twitter right when I started
that I was going to do this and my phone
just keeps vibrating almost non-stop
with people on on Twitter liking that so
that's really cool I mean maybe we'll
get some new viewer
that we haven't had before this is kind
of a different topic it's not exactly
like web development when are you
working with code we're going to be
doing load balancing so I do want to let
you know yesterday someone I forget who
was someone had asked about sink getting
access to the Trello board that I use
for this project so I I did do that I'm
so I made it public and I put the link
to the board in the description for this
video and for yesterday's video so this
is the Trello board that I was using so
now you can see it is public so you can
check it out I don't know if you guys
can hear that vibrating but it's like
it's it's a lot I normally don't get
that many interactions when I when I
announce I'm going to do something on
Twitter so anyway you can check out that
board and just kind of see like get an
idea for how I manage my projects with
Trello and what I still have left to do
and what I've done and you'll get a good
idea for how long it's taken me to do it
so just to bring it back quickly if you
want if you're going to check out the
Trello board these little things they're
not really explained here so I'll
explain them right now the dark blue is
how many Pomodoro sessions I estimated
that that would take the light blue is
how many it actually took so if you're
checking out these tasks and wondering
you know what went into that that that's
it each Pomodoro session is 25 minutes
so it can also give you an idea for how
long things took or you know you could
you could figure out if I'm a fast
worker or a slow worker I don't really
know if I'm fast or slow I don't never
compared myself to anybody else but but
you all requested that so that's
available to you now so yesterday we did
have some some discussion in the live
chat about load balancing and what we
need to do it so I since I'm on
digitalocean already
so the site is hosted on a droplet on
digitalocean I decided like well why
don't I just see if digital ocean has a
tutorial already on it you know they
have pretty good documentation for a lot
of things so I checked in at first I
found some really old tutorials from
like 2012 and I I was not really
comfortable using that because I'm sure
a lot has changed and so then finally I
found one from 2017 and that's the one
that I'm going to use so I linked to it
it's in the description so if you want
to follow along you can check it out as
well if you tuned in for the video where
I set up like the SSL certificate and
the servers initially this is probably
going to be similar to that so if you
thought that was super boring I'm sorry
maybe you might want to do something
else or while you're watching this in
the background but if you're interested
in that then this this will be a good
video for you so not really front and
something I would consider front-end
development which is what I normally do
this I guess you would consider this
more on the backend side of things or
maybe DevOps I'm not sure exactly where
it would fall but this is the this is
the instructions that we're gonna going
to be going off of so sometime recently
so within the last I don't know six
months or so I vaguely remember getting
an email or something from visual ocean
saying that they were including load
balancing and I had forgotten that until
I went to look this up earlier today so
I'm gonna follow this I don't they're
doing it for three I don't need three
I'm only going to set up two droplets so
here's the plan the first step is clone
my droplet or what I forget what it's
called in digital ocean terminology but
the first step is going to be I need a
copy of my major
running to test it we might actually at
first just do like two new droplets so
we can test the load balancing between
those two before I actually move like
the real site onto the load balancer and
because we'll need to point the IP
address and everything so before I do
that let's let's create two droplets and
if I can create these if I can just like
copy these that'll probably be the
fastest way to do it copy and get them
up and running and then we'll set up the
load balancer between those two see if
it works
well point well I think I'm an even go
so far as to point a domain to the to
the load balancer we definitely need to
be careful to make sure the SSL still
works so that's that's going to be
something we need to remember to test uh
and then if it all works and
everything's good
then we'll take down one of the droplets
because I don't need three droplets and
we'll move the live droplet into the
load balancer and at the same time we
will point the actual domain for the
website to the IP address for the load
balancer and not for the droplets
themselves then the load balancer will
take care of the balancing between the
droplets it'll just direct traffic to
either one unless it detects that one is
down I think it's by default it's going
to check every 10 seconds to see if one
is up and if if it detects that you
dropped one of the droplets is down and
we'll just direct everything or the
other one and that's perfect that's
exactly what we want because when we
have one down because we're updating it
or if if something crazy would happen it
actually good you know
legitimately go down for some problem
then it would direct it to the other one
then once we have the first one back
online we'll switch to the other one and
update that so it'll be one extra step
for updating but for that extra step we
will be gaining basically zero downtime
for our site which is awesome because I
think I mentioned yesterday that we have
somewhere between 30 seconds and 45
seconds of downtime which is mitigated
by the fact that we're doing some
aggressive caching
even some some client-side things with a
server service workers so most people
don't actually feel that full 45 seconds
of downtime but I still would rather not
have it uh I just checked the live chat
let me check the live chat just quickly
before we get started just see if
there's any questions if I need to
clarify anything and then we'll get into
it I expected this will be a little bit
of a longer video one because I wasted
the first 20 minutes just trying to get
this set up and if you're just joining
me sorry about the delay I'm streaming
from a different computer and a
different location than I normally do so
the set up was a little weird and has
some unexpected problems so I'm gonna
check this out it looks like so I don't
know how to pronounce it QN oox I'm
pretty sure that's not really somebody's
name if it is let me know how to
pronounce that they mentioned that
digitalocean retweeted my stream
call-out so I did tag digitalocean in
the tweet so that explains why I was
getting so many retweets and likes on
that so thanks thanks for letting me
know I didn't want to take the time to
actually look at my Twitter and figure
that out during the video because that
would not be helpful for you all I'm
sure everybody knows how to use Twitter
here and doesn't doesn't need me to
demonstrate that all right so let me
check there's not a whole lot in the
live stream so this should just take a
minute after I checked the live stream
here then I'm gonna kind of leave it
alone for a little bit and get to work
the random shot says nice website just
checked out the site thank you I
appreciate that thanks for checking it
out and I'm glad you liked it
also has a question would best let
what's the best laptop spec for a web
developer should I get a MacBook okay so
there are some people already answered
that in terms of laptops if
you want my opinion I currently am on a
MacBook Pro I think it's like a 2015
model MacBook Pro so it was the last one
that still had an HDMI port which is
which is why I wanted it it has like the
base specs there's not I don't think I
got the upgraded RAM or anything like
that
so I actually can't even remember I
think maybe I'm running like eight eight
meg I'm sorry eight gigs of RAM
so I wish now that I actually got a
bigger hard drive but at the time I I
didn't want to spend a ton of money on a
new laptop and I just went with a
refurbished one so if I was going to get
a new laptop so I totally I like my
MacBook it's great the display is really
nice it's the the Retina display so it's
like 2k the the touchpad is the nicest
touchpad that I've ever seen on a laptop
that I've ever used so I really like
that and I like that it matches you know
all the touchpad shortcuts and motions
that I use match my work computer which
is an iMac and I use the magic like
touchpad thing with that so that's cool
but if my next computer is going to be a
Linux computer so I have desktop PCs I
have a Chromebook MacBook so I have a
lot of other stuff so I don't if I need
to use those I have them so I think I'm
going to go with Linux I actually just
read a good article I don't say Jess
maybe it was like two months ago or
something but I read an article about
the best laptops for developers that
that run Linux so I can't remember what
that was sorry about that I can't even
remember where I read it from so maybe
if I if I remember during the stream oh
I'll let you know but I would go with
that simply because I'm getting starting
to get used to Linux stuff using it on
servers I be Linux commands are like
pretty much for the command line or like
the same as for Mac so you have the same
stuff
a PC it's a little bit different so I
would kind of like to keep that the same
I with with the ransomware stuff that's
been going around like I've never gotten
ransomware and I'm pretty careful about
things on the internet so I'm not really
worried about it but it's nice that you
know Linux wasn't affected Mac wasn't
either for that reason so anyway
hopefully I answered your question I I
know I didn't give anything specific but
there's also just kind of a factor for
me of Linux is the only operating the
major operating system that I don't have
yet you know I have Mac I have PC I have
Chrome OS so it would be cool to just
have Linux so that I could have all the
different environments that I you know
that that 99% of people in the world are
using for their machine so it that would
be kind of cool to have to have
experience with all of them
alright let me scroll down a lot of this
is just you all letting me know that the
streams either working or not working
all right sky VDS shows some CSS coding
today this is probably not going to be
any CSS so I'm sorry about that
but normally there is CSS so almost
every time I stream I think we've done
at least some CSS so we're going to get
back to that I definitely have on my my
Trello board on my list of to do's
there's a ton of stuff in there that
will require some CSS so I'm going to be
doing that just not today so check me
out a different day it's usually 2 p.m.
Eastern time Monday through Friday if
I'm going to be doing it at a different
time I will I'll put that on Twitter and
you know schedule the time on the free
code camp channel soo so you'll know
about it Marcus says new to free code
camp how good the content from here is
compared to different not free content
like Udacity I'm sure you've probably
got some answers from people in the
stream but more
is that say my brother's name is Marcus
like that name I've done a lot of stuff
from Udacity and some free code camp
Udacity has some some good stuff some of
their stuff is really it's advanced and
very like specific so you'll have a
course that will be specific to one you
know particular topic or niche free code
camp covers like a lot of what you need
for front-end and back-end and it's not
like a very deep dive into one
particular topic so I would say if
you're just beginning
you'll probably be better off starting
with free code camp and then
supplementing with some things from
Udacity but there are some things in
Udacity that I would definitely go with
like the Linux basics and the git and
github course you know go with that
right off the bat because that'll
that'll help you out and as far as I
know that's not covered in free code
camp at least the last time I was I was
in free code camp doing some things that
wasn't really covered so I actually use
both I haven't done any training
recently which kind of stinks I I like
to I like to do a little bit you know
every I'd love to be able to do it every
day but I can't always so but when I was
doing it I was actually going back and
forth between free code camp and mainly
Udacity there are some other things like
like you don't know J ass book that I
was going through so but that's that's
what I recommend and I think in terms of
quality free code camp is good quality
I've done a lot of different free and
mostly free resources I haven't I
haven't done paid I mean I've done
Udacity but that can be a paid resource
but I didn't I just did the free version
of it so I would say quality wise it
definitely compares it just it depends
on what you really need to learn which
you want to learn all right so let me I
want to get to this so I'm just going to
kind of skip a little bit Sebastian your
name did change
to Sebastian in the livestream so
awesome okay so I'm going to cut it off
there and as far as looking at the
livestream so at the end when I'm done
I'll come back and check out what I've
missed but now I want to get to work
because we're pretty far in into the
stream now and we haven't done very much
load balancing alright so the first
thing we're going to do is clone our
droplet so if I go back to droplets I've
never actually clone two droplet like in
the same account like I've made a
snapshot and then transfer the snapshot
to somebody else to a client account so
let's see let's see how we do this or I
can I can try it the smarter way and
just look up how to clone a drop or if
somebody in the live chat has done this
[Music]
let me know
and taking five minutes to figure out
how to do this is going to save us a lot
of time because otherwise we would
actually have to set up droplets you
know manually
okay it looks like we can just take a
snapshot and and then make droplets
based on that snapshot so let's let's
try that so I've done that before okay
Bart just said the same thing in live
chat so thanks let's um let's do that
snapshot
yeah I'm not I'm not gonna power it down
I don't want to power it on the live
site I'm just going to take my chances
with this and hopefully it will all work
maybe I should have powered it on
I don't remember how long this took the
last time I did it does the same normal
that it's taking this long it's not
really an option to cancel it so I guess
we have to wait all right
yeah I'm seeing I'm seeing some new
names in the live chat so welcome if
this is you know your first time
watching or maybe just your first time
chatting thanks for joining in if you
haven't joined before I'll just let you
know kind of while waiting for this to
work this this channel is this dish not
the channel itself but this particular
show on this channel is pretty much just
me doing my my everyday job as a
front-end developer and it's not
rehearsed and mistakes are definitely
included I'm I don't claim to be an
expert in anything so feel free to
correct me in the live chat or in the
comments in the video if you if you
notice I did something wrong or if you
have some suggestions for me that would
be awesome I often have people give me a
suggestion and it ends up helping me out
a lot so hopefully we all learn
something from this I hope you get
something out of it and I know I'm
definitely getting some something out of
this as well you know a lot of a lot of
help and encouragement from you all so
I'm getting impatient with this all
right finally I'm glad I did something I
was like just about to refresh the page
and I'm not sure I'm not sure if I would
have messed anything up if I did that I
made digital oceans pretty pretty on top
of things so I'm sure that they've
thought of what happens if some somebody
refreshes all right so we got a snapshot
created so we should be able to create a
droplet from the snapshot yep so let's
create a droplet
yeah Thor said you should have shut down
your droplet I know it says you should
have shut it down I just didn't want to
take the extra like three seconds to
shut it down I probably should oh so
we'll find out really quickly here if if
it messed anything up but at least for
the purposes of this test if I can just
get my my node server up and running
that's all I need
if it's messed up I can fix it later but
I really just need two droplets with
something up and running even if it was
just HelloWorld but since we already had
this ready I figured you know why not
just clone the the actual droplet so I
want to make sure that I get on the same
data center I did read through the
instructions that I showed you earlier
the the digitalocean instruction
instructions for load balancing and at
some point it mentioned having them on
the same the same data center so I want
to make sure I do that I want to
double-check what data center my
original droplet is on so this doesn't
cause problems later on NYC - okay
that's what I thought but good to go to
double-check we definitely want five
dollar ones and let's see can I make two
yeah yeah awesome I can make two
droplets so I'm just going to name these
oops get on all right two and three
awesome two and three I definitely want
to add my SSH keys and these are the
keys for one of the people that I work
with I'm gonna add those two cuz you
know I might get hit by a car or
something and somebody else needs to be
able to get into this hopefully that
doesn't happen but maybe I'm also going
to set up monitoring I forgot to do that
on my first droplet and you can always
set it up
later on but it's easier just to check
that box let me think
do I need anything else I don't think I
need anything did I shut up I did set
this I just want to try make this as
close as possible to my original droplet
so I think I set that up and I don't say
truth I'm not sure if I need private
networking or not but that's something
that like droplet to droplet networking
that seems like that has something to do
with load-balancing so I'm just gonna
check it it shouldn't mess anything up
and better to just have it even if I
don't need it I guess alright so that's
it everything looks good
I should ok Thor says it shouldn't
matter for load balancing alright so it
won't mess anything up alright cool so
I'm not gonna I'm not gonna uncheck it I
definitely believe you Thor I'm just not
gonna uncheck it because you know why
take another step if it doesn't really
matter and who knows maybe I will use it
someday alright seas are being created
hopefully this doesn't take too long
okay Thor Thor in the live chat says it
will add an additional interface so
since I check that for the droplets to
be to enable private networking awesome
good to go you're awesome that's what I
like digital ocean look at that it's
told me I'm awesome that's that's nice I
mean I know that's auto-generated but at
some point some developer thought it
would be nice to tell people are awesome
so I appreciate that all right so now we
can actually get into the part about
load balancing I guess maybe we should
actually start these servers first so
yeah let's start the service first and
make sure that they're actually working
so I'm going to SSH in and hopefully
everything is is fine with my keys
nice SH keys let me let me make this
bigger because some this looks small to
me so I'm sure it looks really tiny whoa
that was too big
I'm using item as my my terminal and it
does a weird thing when I increase the
font size just by pressing you know like
command + it actually increases the
entire window so you can see like the
whole window is getting bigger so
usually that doesn't happen with every
other program but sometimes it makes it
go on to my other screen and and messes
things up a bit
all right so let's SSH into now I don't
know if this would [ __ ] would actually
copy my user or not so I'm going to act
I'm gonna try to use my my username from
out of the droplet if not I'll just try
to go into route and see if that works
because I actually I don't think I ever
went in a disabled route like the I
intended to do so if you remember when
we were setting up the droplet
originally the plan was get everything
set up
and then once we were confident we
didn't need to mess with route type of
stuff anymore we would just totally shut
it down and we still have be able to use
sudo with with my username so I think I
copy this let me yes it works so good to
know if you copy a droplet from a
snapshot it does retain your username so
you see I was able to get right in with
my SSH key right into my user so that's
awesome so let's see alright um I'm just
gonna CD in here and just see like okay
that looks good it looks like everything
that was on the other one so we should
be able to do start actually let me see
I think it status it's already online
awesome so no way it's just hello is
online let me go to the IP address and
see because our our instance was not a
hello we did have originally a little Oh
world page so let's see what's going on
no way alright it did run amazing whoa
that's that's not at all what how was
that
alright I'm I'm a little bit confused
here and sorry if my inexperience of
this might be coming out but I'm I click
this one did I click the wrong IP
address or are all my redirects and
things alright so I had not expected
this to happen I thought that I would
have to do some extra setup but it seems
like everything is copied over and
working including the fact that it's
this is just weird uh because I assume
my IP address all right or my domain is
pointed to an IP address right it
shouldn't be it's just redirecting me
right that's what's happening so because
my my nginx reverse proxy is set up to
redirect all traffic is that's what
happened maybe that's what's happening
and I'm gonna go back to the live chat
and see if somebody's
that's it yeah so Thor Thor saying yeah
I guess the web server is redirecting so
yeah if a few maybe like two or three
weeks ago or something we set this up
and we're using nginx as a reverse proxy
so it's possible that that is
redirecting the problem that I'm seeing
here is well if this is just redirecting
me to to this droplet this original
droplet then like how how am I supposed
to know one if these droplets are really
working
awesome okay so I was saying awesome
authority found the channel through
digital ish and retweeting me so that
that's awesome
I kind of thought maybe I would get some
new people when I when I found out that
they had retweeted me so that's cool so
yeah and some somebody was asking about
my front end dev because I'm yet so this
is not front-end stuff but I do have to
do some back-end stuff occasionally but
normally I am normally I do front-end
stuff so I would say that's I don't know
like 90 percent 85 90 percent of my job
I think would be front-end stuff and the
rest would be back-end and DevOps and
I'm like totally ignoring the fact that
I'd have to do the design work as well
so I just lump that into the front-end
but we su could separate that out all
right so let me bring my my terminal in
here and we can check check new projects
pointing the new IP their log engine ik
access okay let's go
I know this is the slow way of going
through here but I like to see the
folders to give just like so I can make
a mental picture of where everything's
at so the more I see it the more it'll
stick in my mind cool
whoa all right so we have some access
logs all right so the Thor just gave me
a nice command here tail
what's I've never used the tail command
before what's tail going to do
you
Oh awesome okay good enough just learned
a new command tale lists the last ten
lines of the file so you can see new
lines floating it awesome I like that
and the F will do a lot cool all right
so I'm just copying and pasting that in
No
did you mean why is this not working
okay so it's not installed by default
okay so it's just Aptus oh okay this
shows uh this is um Lubuntu 16.04 so if
you're watching the recording of this
later on it's probably a little bit hard
for you to follow there's a lot of
back-and-forth going on between the
people in the live chat and and me so
sorry if it's hard to follow I'll try to
read off what's going on the live chat
as much as I can so this video is at
least somewhat intelligible later on
okay so I'm going to try so Bart in the
live chat is giving me a command to
install this this package that will let
me read my log files and that will give
me an idea of what's actually going on
with my my server so I'm going to try to
start right now
awesome and I already have it so how do
I not
okay so I'm not exactly sure why it's
not working so let me just let me try
this command again now it's still giving
me that all right so that's Cecily going
to work so let's um cheating
should I try it let's try it with sudo
no not not fun okay
not expect this part of the
load-balancing to give me this much
trouble so I mean we're literally on
like the the step 1 of the of the
documentation oops
and we're together there we go okay is
there something
is there something else that I can
either use to read that log or can we
think of some other way to just see
what's going on would it be worthwhile
to I said if you can fit two points in
an IP and restart it
so yeah maybe it's the config this is
what I'm thinking is there something in
my nginx config that I should change now
that I've changed this and will that
will that make a difference should I
just take out the redirect okay so Bart
says maybe there was some corruption in
a core file or something like that maybe
because I did not stop my server and
then make the snapshot so that's it's
entirely possible all right I'm gonna
try I'm gonna try this one more time
nope it's not saying it's inhabiting all
right so I'm gonna go see I'm gonna do
this um I need to get to I can never
remember where the nginx config file
live so somebody knows often where that
is um they can let me know it'll save me
some time from trying to look it up I
don't do it often enough to remember it
so I always just have to look it up here
here's my plan basically I'm gonna go to
my nginx config and accept okay that's
where it starts at the e.t.c folder I
think I put I have my um default yeah
okay all right so let me take
yeah Thor says argh nano which you're
all you're right I do have to run it a
pseudo another thing I frequently forget
I'm gonna get out of nano now because I
need to run it I can view it right now
but I can't edit it unless I run it as
pseudo okay uh Thor what what editor do
you use if you say them then you're my
hero
uh I just just have said them uh I've
tried them it's just like I'm not I'm
not good with it yet I need more
practice
so I've seen people use them and and
it's it's amazing uh it's a skill that I
would like to have one day all right we
we've got at least three people in here
using them so so you all now are have
have my respect for sure not not that
you didn't have it before but Wow okay
so Thor says vim actually has syntax
highlighting so I'm I'm sold on it for
that reason alone all this white text
and then it drives me crazy I actually
sometimes just use FileZilla and get my
files and then open them in my code
editor just to get the syntax
highlighting so let me see what I need
to do here uh my my idea here is simply
to just serve this stuff on port 80
right or whatever the default port is
yeah port 80 or I don't I don't really
care about the SSL right now I guess so
you just go with port 80
and not do a redirect so this is our
redirect right yeah if I turn this yeah
so let's say I comment this out and is
the server name is the server name
something that is required I don't know
we'll find out oops what did I just do I
just switch windows sorry um okay so
what I need to make sure those that I'm
doing where's this stuff this okay so
the routes still here is this soon
it's hard to tell what where these
brackets start and stop okay so this is
the start about this let's just take I'm
gonna look at the live chat in a second
if if you if you're if you're typing in
live chat that I'm doing this wrong I'll
look in a second my idea is simply this
server block was ending here and this
one was beginning but I'm just I'm just
going to keep it going so basically it's
not gonna end it's not going to begin a
new one I'm gonna comment out this SSL
stuff just for the time being and oops
and hopefully I don't do I need this
I don't remember yeah I don't want these
ssl config snippets so let's see that
should that should take me back to what
I like had originally before we setup
the SSL or at least be close to it okay
thoughts I have to comment out the
listen stuff to let me go back in
quickly oh did you mean this list and
stuff maybe that I forgot there was a
delay so it's possible that that was
tight before I did that so I'm gonna get
back out okay I should really ask
questions using the by typing in the
live chat and then we would be in sync
in terms of at least you wouldn't see
what I'm doing on the screen but at
least we could talk back and forth at
the same time alright so I need to
restart nginx
which one is it sudo nginx I think it's
just restart right
you
there's a system control that's it
that's it
okay now let's try to go to this IP
address and see if if I totally mess it
up or if we're going to get something so
it shouldn't redirect us anymore and it
did dang it okay so how did we still get
redirected
alright so let's get rid of these
[Music]
yeah Umberto asked did I restarted the
server shoot for mentions I used 301 so
it that tells us that it's a permanent
redirect basically so it's possible that
this is a cache issue so maybe I just
need to let's see did I type it wrong
was that something who caught that I
typed it wrong awesome that's that's a
good problem to have
okay I didn't alright saying I didn't
type it wrong I'll restart it again just
to uh sudo to you know CTL or yes to
your team's next yeah that was that
looks right um all right so let's try a
let's try some things here no that's not
I don't want to restart that and I would
restart this one or I could just try it
all right yes progress haha I got a 502
but this is most happy I've ever been to
see a bad gateway error all right we're
getting somewhere
all right so progress has been made and
let's I assume that I messed something
up and that I need to then I need to
edit this file that I just edited
you
so let me check this out actually do I
have yeah so I'm going to open this I'm
gonna make it big so everybody watching
live can see this and check it out and
see Oh guys the reverse proxy part is
wrong that's what I'm Thor saying in the
live chat I'm so glad that so many of
you who are knowledgeable about this
decided to watch today and actually I am
I'm check on my other screen I'm
checking the let me see I don't sell
nginx I'm checking the setup like the
original setup that I used for this like
when I first tested my hello world my
hello world app
you
actually I want to check on my other
screen I'm going to check really quick
in my server Jas file to see to make
sure what what port I'm actually running
this on or localhost just to
double-check just on the off-chance I
set it on something weird if they've no
it shouldn't hide so as long as my dev
server is for three thousand but my
production is 8080 alright so I was
pretty sure that was it but did not want
to waste a bunch of time if it was
something silly like that so we're gonna
at location ok so this block looks like
it's exactly the same as what I did have
it on at first
who
so that's weird
I wanna run um I just wanted to make
sure everything was ok with my syntax at
least
you
okay so all right so we I'm getting I'm
getting several different suggestions
here so I'm gonna check with p.m. to
again just to see like okay we're
running hmm let's say I'm gonna stop
that and
let's see I need to actually let me do
this because I just want to see I think
start let me let me check how I have
this in my package.json here I think
it's just start yeah
empty everyone start there we go
but I just need to be in oh yeah of
course that didn't work I need to be in
the right folder for that to work all
right okay so let me refresh this okay
and that was it
for whatever reason p.m. - did start up
something right off the bat but it
whatever it was started up this Hello
app I don't really know what that was or
what it was doing but it was not I guess
it wasn't this so yeah so honestly at
this point just to continue this I'm
just going to leave this here because
that's all we really needed to happen we
just needed this to run so that we can
test out the load balancing so I'm going
to do exactly the same thing that we
just did - all the stuff that didn't
work on this other droplet and then we
can get on with it so let me grab the IP
of this other droplet and let's go in
okay nano and what was that et Cie was
it nginx
now shoot lose the next one trying to
find it I know somebody already typed
this in so I'm not even gonna gonna ask
again there we go
I think that was it why didn't that work
there you go and that's that's not we
had it in sites available and it was
default correct okay all right so in a
No
sorry this is still small on your screen
I'm only leaving it small because um I'm
doing the exact thing that we just did
so it's just easier for me to see it all
at once so we are commenting out this
this line and this line we're commenting
out this part where it ends that block
and begins a new block and then we're
commenting out the words listening for
the SSL and where we included snippets
for the SSL and that should be all we
did yep that's all we did so and I'm
pretty sure I forgot the sudo so this is
not going to work let's say haha dang it
alright so we're gonna have to not save
the changes and I'm gonna have to use
sudo this time I told you I always
forget that and I literally forgot it
after five minutes
all right
so let's do this again at least I'll
probably get good at this since I'm
having to redo it
oops it's not yeah I know it's not I
mean no we just talked about them and
how I'm no good with them but it's not
really like nanos that much more user
friendly it seems like once you get used
to using them people can just fly around
and do whatever they need to and then so
it seems like that's definitely the way
to go if you can learn it okay and that
looks like everything that needed to be
commented up and now that will work
since we used to tow and now all I need
to do is go in here and do NPM run start
and that should start up this one and we
will double check quickly by going to
this IP address and probably need to
refresh oops
I'm sure you all caught this I didn't
look at the live chat I forgot to
restart nginx
so let's do that
okay now let's see if this will work
okay we got the bad gateway so that's
what we're looking for
all right and that's running awesome so
at this point we have two copies just a
quick recap here's our main site it's
running and this is fine this has the
domain name pointed to it but we've made
two exact copies and we've edited the
config for nginx
slightly so that we can reach these at
these IP addresses because otherwise it
was redirecting us back to this site so
now we should be able to continue on
with setting up load balancing between
these two to test it out and hopefully
get it working on here so let me scroll
down here to see see la chat I'm
laughing because I just did I scrolled
down to the bottom of the live chat I
scrolled up a little bit to look up a
command and they're like I don't know
and maybe ten messages saying you sudo
an exclamation point sudo sudo so I knew
you won't caught it and I didn't catch
it so it's actually if you've never
tried live coding before on YouTube or
any other place where you can do live
coding I'm it's really nice to have all
these people looking at the code when
you're coding I usually work alone and
so I never have other people looking at
my code and at first when I thought
about live-streaming
the thought of other people looking at
my code was scary but now
I see that I mean I'm sure there are
some people to look at my code and think
wow this guy is a noob but there's a lot
of other really nice people like you all
in the live chat here that look at my
code and offer amazing suggestions and
feedback for me and catch my mistakes
before I catch them so I appreciate that
yeah I will I will be checking the chat
there is a delay there's about a minute
delay so the stuff that I'm doing you
all won't see for another minute so so
part part of the reason why it seems
like I'm not checking the chat is
because that also honestly sometimes I
just do forget to check the chat so
hahaha alright so evidently as I went
through and it said I said that you know
they were saying pseudo with exclamation
points I assume they were just yelling
pseudo at me but pseudo with two
exclamation points is actually command
so I apologize for the frustration that
I must be causing you but by
misunderstanding with what's going on
here so I don't know what's okay so
brings in the previous command and
that's shooter that line oh my goodness
that command is gonna change my life
okay so this is a an excellent excellent
thing that was just brought up here so I
don't know how to say this with the
users Q and X so if you're you doing a
command with when you want to use sudo
let me let me bring up a window where I
actually have I can write in so so let's
say you want to do something sudo if you
just type in like you've typed in the
command once right so I don't even know
something I could
chiming of a long command I could do I
can't think of something on the spot
that would be wrong but let's say let's
say that I typed in a really long
command but I forgot to use sudo right
so I hit enter and I'm like oh man I
forgot to use sudo instead of having to
type that command in again or having to
do like I just did where I actually like
scrolled back with my arrow keys all the
way the beginning if I just typed in
sudo and then - exclamation points it
will actually bring up the previous
command and then add the word sudo at
the beginning so I don't have to do that
and that is awesome
that's an amazing tip so if you only get
one thing useful out of this live stream
today if it's only that then I think
that's worth all the time of doing this
live stream and thank you so much for
telling me that because that that is
going to save me I don't it's going to
save me like a few seconds here and
there but it's going to add up over the
course of time to probably a lot of time
and a lot of frustration gone because of
that command so thank you very much okay
so now we can finally get on with
actually setting up the load balancing I
hope that at least I know there's a lot
of people in the live chat a lot of
people watching right now that are you
know this has probably been a little bit
painful to watch me go through this and
you you've already got this down and you
know what's going on
but I at least hope that there are some
people who have never done this kind of
thing before and you're getting some
type of value out of this
so I mean hopefully there's some value
in the you know kind of fumbling through
this for the last hour
so the droplets are now up and we have a
site running on each of them so that get
brings us to step two of our
documentation if you're following along
the link is in the description this is
step two
so we need to go to load balancers I'm
going to move it to my other screen so
that I can actually do this on this
screen and you all can watch I'm going
to make it a little bit bigger for you
will didn't want to do that I need to go
here anyway so networking load balancers
so now we're going to create a load
balancer and create load balancer build
hourly at three cents no additional
bandwidth charges okay so I'm gonna
create this load balancer I'm assuming
that this is within budget twenty
dollars a month is not a huge deal and
we're actually saving money in terms of
where we were going to host it at before
so what was budgeted for we're still
under that so I'm not too worried about
this and if anybody is watching from
where I work and you know the budget
stuff better than me please warn me now
before I purchase this
okay awesome I just checked the stream
because I remember you all told me to
keep checking so let's see okay yeah so
some people are getting something out of
it and some people saying they're
watching because they like to teach and
I appreciate you you watching okay so
actually Thor Thor says he never stood
up load-balancing before so you've been
helping me out so much in this dream so
hopefully you can get something as well
out of this and when we can set up load
balancing Rohan don't worry about it I
didn't take offense to your comments oh
so don't don't worry at all no no
offense taken
Rohan was was he was referencing
something else like as a joke but it
seemed somewhat rude so don't worry
about it I'm not really uh I've been
pleasantly surprised at how few people
have been rude to me since I've started
doing this so I mean you all have been
great I was actually expecting more
people to come in and be like critical
in a mean way
so don't don't worry about it I'm sure
I'm due for some of it someday but for
now you all been been awesome all right
so we need to make a name for a load
balancer so I guess I'm just going to
call it CCI load balance catechetical
Institute is the like the department
where I work that I'm making the site
for so that's why everything is prefixed
with CI so I know I'm really unique with
my names but some it says what it does
it'll work so we need both we prefix
everything with CI or droplet so this
should be easy yep we had two and three
awesome so we already have the right
regions oh okay Thor says he when he
sees CI he thinks continuous integration
system using
honestly before I started this project I
thought the same thing see I always
meant continuous integration and in the
first couple of meetings when people
were using CI that's what I thought too
but now that I've been working on this
so much
my brain is shifted and now I do think
of CI as catechetical Institute but I'm
glad you brought up continuous
integration because that's something I'm
really interested in so if anybody
listening now has any good resources or
something that you use for continuous
integration please put it in the
comments or direct message me on Twitter
I think there's a link to my Twitter in
the description or you can put it in the
live chat because I would love to know
what you all use or what your
suggestions are for that alright so we
need to load balance set out traffic
will be routed from the load balancer to
your droplets okay so for now I think
this will work at some point we do need
HTTPS but but right now or our droplets
aren't using HTTPS so just to test I'm
going to leave it like this I'm assuming
that I can change this later on if not
I'll have to just make another but load
balancer which yeah I guess I'll do I
won't do it live I won't make you go
through all that but maybe I'll okay so
this looks good let's look at our our
default values so round-robin um if
you're not familiar with some of these
uh I'll go through a little bit and I'm
not an expert I've just read up on it a
bit before this round-robin means like
it's just going to pass off each session
to different servers it's not going to
check like the load on the servers or
anything like that so it's just kind of
spreading things out Zac gasps is this
an advanced topic um I guess so I don't
know it depends on where you're coming
from if somebody was a back-end
developer this is probably not that
advanced for them but for me as a
front-end developer this seems pretty
advanced for me because it's not what I
usually do I I have to do it
occasionally when I first setup acai
but then I usually don't have to mess
with it again
so depends on where you're at I don't
know maybe you all have a better idea of
what kind of the level that I'm working
at here whether it's advanced or not
okay cool thanks a few people are
putting their preferences for continuous
integration and cool that's helpful oh
I'll go back after this video I'll make
sure I go back into the chat and check
out your suggestions I'll look them up
and see because I haven't even heard of
some of these ones that you're
suggesting so I'm interested to find out
what their what they're like um for
right now I guess this would be fine I
kind of want to click this just to show
you let's let's do it so just for the
sake of learning I'll just show you
these options so it looks like we could
do round-robin like I said it just
splits everything up evenly this
actually kind of more intelligently
routes things so whatever droplet has
the least load it goes to I actually
kind of like that one better I wonder
what the if there's some type of
performance trade-off for this as
opposed to the other one they don't
really explain it
but I think I'm gonna go with this one
because I I could see this being of more
value I mean I there's got to be some
trade-off with performance or something
because otherwise everyone would just
pick this one okay I don't need to track
people so I'm not gonna worry about this
cookie thing we're not I'm not doing any
anything with that currently let's see
health checks okay so we could actually
set our own interval right now it's in
ten-second intervals
so cool I think I'm not gonna mess with
that at some point we will need to
change this to use HTTPS but not right
now and we're not going to redirect this
right now so right now like we commented
out all our HTTPS stuff anyway so I
don't want to do this now but at some
point we will probably set those so
let's create this load balancer great it
seems like we've just fast forwarded
through so much now after that struggle
in the beginning so if you want to know
more about all that stuff that I just we
just saw those options check out the
link in my description to the
digitalocean documentation for load
balancing it actually it explains in
more depth each one of those options all
right so now if you are following along
as soon as this this bar gets all the
way up here we're going to be on step 3
which is testing
okay I'm gonna check back in the
livestream now since while we're waiting
are the live chat sorry okay so some of
the continuous integration stuff that
that you that are being suggested here
in the live chat just in case your you
can't leave you the chat right now or
you're watching the recording later on
is a circle CI app Thayer Jenkins I have
heard of Jenkins I haven't heard
together too yet
okay so Sean says in terms of backend uh
he says this is fairly simple because
digitalocean does all the heavy lifting
for you automatically it would be
advanced if you had to setup all
manually yeah definitely when I was
first thinking about doing this and I I
didn't realize the digitalocean did all
this I mean you pay more right it's like
20 bucks a month for them to handle it
all but honestly like in terms of how
many hours it would take me to probably
set it up manually that 20 dollars is
not really a big deal compared to you
know what what my company would have to
pay me to set that up and maintain it
all myself
so I I think they're saving money by me
going this route so yeah I was a little
bit afraid of having to do it all
manually I mean it was like fear mix
with excitement you know sometimes it's
cool to like tackle some big difficult
thing but at the same time you know
there's just so many hours in the day I
have other projects so it wasn't sure
I'd have the time to get to it Alex asks
do you recommend JavaScript for
programmer he says do you recommend lean
JavaScript for programmer I'm assuming
you set meant learn JavaScript or is
there something called lean JavaScript
and I miss misunderstanding so assuming
your meaning do you recommend learning
JavaScript I'm gonna say yeah but I mean
I'm this is coming from somebody who
primarily uses JavaScript so I think
most
people would recommend that you learn
you know the thing that they that they
know so the reason that I am going with
JavaScript is because there are a lot of
jobs for JavaScript right now and there
are a lot of things that can be built
with JavaScript and JavaScript can be
used on both the client side and the
server side so it offers me the
opportunity to focus my time and my
training on one language instead of
multiple languages and be able to build
apps completely you know front-end and
back-end with just one language so for
me it's like it's a time-saving thing of
you know I'd know I don't have all the
time in the world to spend learning
things so why not just learn one
language that I can build complete
things with instead of having to learn
two different languages I have done some
stuff with I built a calculator once in
C++ I've done something so I've done
very very basic minor stuff in other
languages majority what I do is in
JavaScript all right so this is now up
we're gonna check out this IP address
now and it should route us to a site and
it did it did and I have a big smile on
my face right now
so technically at this point we've we've
done load balancing alright there's
definitely still some some testing right
I want to we want to actually stop one
of our servers and then try it again to
make sure it's it's actually switching
the right way and then we need to get it
working with the domain name and with
the SSL the domain name thing is
actually going to be really easy and I
can do that right now
I already have a test domain name set up
so I'm going to point it to that to that
address
let me see I'm going to do login and
stuff on my other screen and then I can
show you what what I'm doing
II
all right so let me let me make sure I
copy this IP so I get the right one and
I'll bring over just in case you haven't
seen how to how to work with domains or
not I'll bring over this screen it's
this your screen is going to look a
little bit different depending on where
you're where you purchase your domain
where you're managing it from let's see
okay so check this out if you watched
our maybe a few weeks ago we work with
this before I'm going to bring this up
just a bit though I just check the live
chat formats and C and C++ not really a
great idea for beginners yeah I mean I
did a good I did well in the class I got
a really good grade this was in college
I took a course on it is one of my few
computer related courses that I took
because my degrees in business but I did
really well in it I got a good grade and
I always got the assignments done you
know really quickly but it didn't it
didn't make me want to do any type of
programming alright so basically here's
our records this is just a list of our
this is our main domain right so we have
this is pointed to our main digitalocean
droplet right that's live right now it's
just at and we're using the a address
this is a double UW version so you do
have to have a separate WW version if
you want people to be able to get to
their lab from typing nww and then these
are all the subdomains so we have our WP
sub domain is where our WordPress
back-end for this site is is living and
then we have this test one so I'm going
to change the test one if you remember
that used to be pointed to two here you
step this IP address but now we're going
to we're going to change that I'm going
to save it and if this if this takes a
while to
for it to work you know like let's say
it's still cash on the other one then
I'm not going to stick around for that
I'm just going to skip to the next part
of testing and then if it kicks in and
starts working later on then that's
great we can we can test it there we go
hmm maybe
all right so I'm just gonna go back like
I said I I don't know if if that'll kick
in but at least I have it pointed there
so it'll it'll kick it at some point if
you remember last time we tried to point
a domain it was like it was a lot it was
way longer than I thought it would be I
think it was we wait around for like a
half an hour
okay so Thor said it is working fine a
crime there so awesome so yeah it's
probably just some sort of caching on my
end and so not really a big deal
I didn't it's not like I expected that
that would not work that's pretty pretty
simple so so let's just stop one of
these servers and I mean obviously it
should work but you know let's test it
or my um so I'm trying to find my um
there it is oh all right so let's go to
one of these and I just stopped stop
that and let's see what I actually have
to shut down nginx here's what I want to
know do does it need to completely shut
down or if it gets an error because my
node server shutdown will that be enough
and I don't know if I'll know that for
sure I'm assuming that it would take an
error message yeah so let's
shut us out
I just checked the analytics quickly and
we have 42 viewers though I'm I'm
pleasantly surprised and impressed
because this has been a really long
stream so far so okay I get Patrick says
I get the 502 without the node server so
that should work okay so that's um
that's what I want so if I don't think I
explained what I was just talking about
properly so I was kind of thinking out
loud so basically in the documentation
for digitalocean
to test this they recommend just
stopping nginx to test but that's not
what will happen like for me for this
site I'm not I don't completely stop
nginx when I update the site it stays
running what I do stop temporarily is
the node server so what I want to happen
is if nginx is still running on a
droplet but the node server is down I
want the load balancer to go to the
other server that has everything still
up and running so that's I'm not exactly
sure the only way I know how to test
that is to change something on one of
these sites and then um then I could
actually tell which one I'm being
directed to anybody have a better idea I
kind of don't I don't really want to
take the time yeah a troll man or as
soon as troll it is says HTTP is not
working so yeah that's fun I didn't set
up the HTTPS oh the access log yes
awesome so Thor says check the access
look so that all right so let's say I
don't know if I even want to attempt
this acts as well before since I failed
at it last time let's see I'm just I'm
thinking for a second like is it worth
it to take the time to really change
stuff and try to test this now because
otherwise I will eventually I will
actually have to change something like
and by ventia I mean like either later
today or tomorrow morning I will really
actually make an update to the site and
then it will be obvious whether or not
this is working so I guess I could gesso
Thor actually just gave me the exact
command so I can copy and paste so thank
you for that it's definitely going to be
easy enough now ah pseudo right so let's
do any pseudo nice oh wow okay and then
shift okay
you
all right so this is telling me all the
write the traffic that I'm getting so
what I should do now correct me if I'm
wrong is go back here a few times and
keep track of what's going on so let me
let me make sure I know what this last
okay so in 1958 forty five so I'm gonna
go to this this site a few times
I have to re-up it okay so this one this
one doesn't do the library loading so I
have to reopen it okay good all right so
the other one that I was trying to use
it wouldn't work earlier in this stream
it would have library loaded so I
actually do have to stop this one and
what's how do I get out of this one
what's the proper command here Q all
right Q there's only like four different
options to get out of something on the
command line so just I just try them all
okay so let's just try this again and
what was that Comanche was that it or
shift shift Jake okay hmm
okay so some stuff was definitely
happening uh we're definitely getting
some some traffic now I know it's it's
every 10 seconds it's going to be
sending checks so I'm assuming most of
these are probably those ten-second
checks right because these are all
10-second intervals
okay let's see since I can reload by
typing II I don't do that
so first and I just type II and then
enter is that I didn't seem to do
anything for me maybe I'm doing it wrong
I got a suggestion to try to refresh
this it doesn't look like it's working
yeah let's um I'll tell you what I don't
want to spend a ton of time uh because I
don't want to waste your time with this
I just had a thought
let's just say that this doesn't work in
fact nginx itself has to be down for the
load balancing to work properly and
recognizing the server's down that's not
necessarily a big deal when I go to
update I just have like a string of
update commands anyway like that I copy
and paste in I can just add to that to
stop nginx temporarily so that that
stops as well
everything gets updated then it restarts
as the last thing and so if worse comes
to worse and it doesn't work like I
wanted to I can just stop nginx at the
same time and you know it doesn't really
matter so since I'm having trouble with
this I'm sure that you all could
probably figure out probably an innocent
alas or you get it in a new monkey okay
actually I'm gonna try one more thing
because I had something in so it's gone
what goes in there know what I do
shoot ahead move
[Music]
okay awesome so that actually works so
here's a cool trick this does not live
reload if you use less to access this
but if you see what I just did I typed
in a colon and then E and then just
random characters and hit enter
it says no such file or directory but
when it goes back in it actually updates
it so I don't have to go back out and
come back and it is updated and I think
we're getting the same thing here which
is basically five
I'm sorry ten second intervals which
makes sense because it's set to check at
ten seconds so these these are not like
people checking this obviously uh you
know we wouldn't have such nice
integrals so I'm gonna assume and this
isn't we have I don't think this is like
a decisive test but I think it's at
least somewhat safe to assume that the
traffic is not coming from from outside
yet and that this is all just coming
from our load balancer so that's at this
point in in the process that's okay for
me okay let's see / is it prune ad is
that it sorry I can't I have the live
chat up on my one of my old monitors
that's the resolution is low so the text
is kind of weirdly squished together but
so I haven't trouble reading that name
but somebody in the live chat just said
isn't a left more useful it's definitely
a more useful but for some reason it's
not working and I say I've never used it
but based on what you all have said it
would be more useful definitely so all
right so let me get out of here and
let's just go on with what what we need
to do here
um I'm skipping down if you're following
along
I'm skipping down because some of these
are just basic nginx commands that we
don't even need you know we don't need
right now it doesn't necessarily have
anything to do with load balancing
someone step well step 5 doesn't matter
um basic stuff okay so actually we've
completed the entire um guide on now
shoot I was on the wrong guide wasn't a
sorry so I'm sorry that seemed too easy
okay um actually we did yeah so we
completed both guys I had two guides
open up at the same time one was a guide
that was just on nginx the other was on
load balancing but also using nginx on
the server so I was switching back and
forth between the two that's why I was
confused for a second but basically um
we've gone through a step three we've
pretty much kind of tested it right I
I'm not like uh maybe like 90% sure that
it's working the way that I want it to
work and I'll have confirmation soon
about that
[Music]
let me test failover
oh man let's let me let me check this
out on digital ocean here for a second
um let's go in here and see if I had
just read farther in the instructions
this would have saved so much time our
our number two droplet that we took down
node on but not nginx is actually
reading is down and it's been down for a
while so that is confirmation that we
needed that in fact as long as we notice
down even if nginx is still up it's
still gonna count it is down that's what
we need so excellent that's what we
wanted now having more droplets
basically the process to add more
droplets seems really simple you
literally just go to add more droplets
and you add a droplet and then it'll
work so the basically what we need to do
now which I'll probably I'm probably not
going to do it now because this has been
such a long stream if you're just
joining for the first time I try to my
goal is to keep my streams to half an
hour but I usually fail with that my
streams are closer to an hour sometimes
like somewhere between a half an hour an
hour so this stream has definitely been
way longer than normal I did get started
late because I was streaming on a new on
a different computer that I normally do
and so I had some some issues or it
wasn't the audio or the video wasn't
displaying properly so I think this is
gonna probably be a two-parter so
tomorrow at 2 p.m.
unless something weird happens I should
be able to streaming
tomorrow 2:00 p.m. I will go over how to
configure the SSL to work so I'm not
going to work on this anymore we'll pick
up right where we left off the only
thing I'm going to do is I'm going to
read up on how to do configure the SSL
so at the bottom of the instructions
that we've been going through that I
have linked in the description
it actually has links to configuring
your SSL so that there can you know we
can have encryption like we need to so I
don't know does that sound like a plan I
had hope to get through everything I
thought that was kind of ambitious since
I've never done it before so I really
didn't have a way to tell how long it
was going to be so alright so seems like
this works I'm right now I'm going to go
through the live chat quickly just to
see if anybody had any questions that I
missed and after that then I'm gonna I'm
gonna end the the chat and/or the live
stream and I'll be back tomorrow so if
you just here for the actual you know
the demo of doing this then and you
don't care to stay around for the
questions then thanks for watching
and you know what you know join me again
tomorrow to see the rest of it or some
other day 2:00 p.m. Eastern Time Monday
through Friday otherwise if you want to
stick around or if you have any
questions put them in the live chat chat
now I'll try to get to them if you if
you can't stick around but you still
won't ask a question you can put it in
the comments to this video or you can
direct message me on Twitter and I'll
try to get getting you an answer as soon
as I can
okay so I'm just kind of scrolling
through here the live chat and there's a
lot so I'm going to be scrolling through
quickly so there's a good chance I might
miss something I apologize in advance if
I missed your question
it looks like there's a lot of good back
and forth discussion between you on the
live chat which is also my I like that
okay I'm just gonna read this comic it's
nice positive comment Brent Brent or I
don't know how I'm assuming that this
three in the middle of this name is
meant to be an e so I'm going to say
Brent or it says I find setting up and
configuring this stuff super fun awesome
I'm glad well you do the last time I did
something like this I think I did have
some comments that like it was a boring
or something I don't know if it was as
harsh as that but I some some people I
think we're expecting more of like CSS
JavaScript stuff and we're doing a lot
of just command line things so I'm glad
you enjoyed it
I think this stuff's kind of fun I don't
know if I'd want to do this day in and
day out like everything but I enjoy it
when I when I do have to do it
Sean commented this really interesting
video glad to be able to see this being
done for forever need to set up myself
yeah I mean I think I made a lot of
mistakes during this and it took a lot
longer than it should have but you know
hopefully like if you just see where I
messed up at and that helps you to avoid
it and that's I'm happy that I can at
least help in that way so even my my
mistakes could hopefully help help
somebody out
okay we have another continuous
integration solution here that is
mentioned is Travis so they were I
mentioned a few other ones earlier on I
had asked I'd asked everyone in the live
chat to you know if they're using
continuous integration you know how are
they doing it what are they using so I
didn't mention Travis before Thor Thor
mentioned Travis
also we mentioned skit lab because uh
good luck serious noise so that's that q
ni o X I'm going to I'm going to call
you Q nukes because it's easier than
spelling the name out so Q nukes
mentions gitlab is nice for continuous
integration Sebastian said I can hear
your MacBooks fans I couldn't actually I
always have headphones on playing music
so that I have a tendency to speak kind
of low you know and maybe mumble a
little bit so I want to make sure you
all can hear me so I put headphones on
and play music and it helps me to talk
louder because I can't really hear
myself that well and also it helps me to
not be distracted by other noises which
actually I think somebody is mowing
their lawn my neighbor is which is like
constant eye I can't stand it there's
always somebody mowing their lawn next
to me so there's never any like quiet so
I apologize if you hear in the
background noise but I believe it I I'm
actually I'm proud of my laptop now I
was wondering how it would stand you
know the the livestream but so far it's
been fine earlier today it just totally
froze up I had to completely restart it
and I wasn't even doing anything else I
had some browser windows open a code
editor and Spotify and I mean that was
you know not not that much
Zak ass is nishan similar to Heroku
firebase or AWS and Zach also got lots
of answers there
so some answers AWS definitely some yeah
I would say it's most similar now I'll
say this I haven't I've only played
around with Heroku and I haven't ever
used firebase but I would say agree it's
definitely the most similar to AWS and I
think AWS came out with like a direct
competitor to digitalocean that's like
super simple to use as then they came
out with that sometime within the last I
don't I don't know for sure it was for
sure within the last year though I don't
remember what it's called
everything has a weird name on AWS I
can't keep him straight
Jose asks when deploying updates to
production what's the best tool pushing
code to multiple servers and let's see I
know he probably got some answers here
so for says some kind of continuous
integration Patrick Heroku is nice
oh shoot the Lord said my voice was gone
hopefully it wasn't it didn't go off for
too long I haven't I've been paying
attention to the stream health so I
apologize hopefully it didn't cut out
and didn't cut out at all hopefully or
at least not to too much yeah I think
Jose when deploying updates to
production for multiple servers I don't
know what I'm going to use now but I do
have multiple servers that are need to
be like mirrored and have the same thing
so I'm still thinking about what I'm
going to use at at this point right now
my process for updating this this server
this droplet on digital ocean is to
actually use SSH to go into the server
and then I do a get pull and then I
rebuild the app
and I started again so I would love to
be able to have a more automated way to
do that like let's say every time I push
code to github on the master branch it
automatically does all that I think that
that is possible I just don't know how
to do it so if anybody knows how to do
something like that or knows of like a
totally different solution that would be
even better let me know please that I
would like to know so I'm still kind of
trying to figure that out myself
Zach gasps does anyone have some good
recommendations on books about getting
better at problem solving hmm I'm not
sure about problem solving in general I
mean I guess that doesn't even have to
be related to coding at all I don't have
I don't know of anything off the top of
my head for problem solving if you want
something that's more coding related I
would say like a book that has like
challenges for you maybe like algorithm
challenges or things will force you to
solve problems so the more you do that
the better you'll get now I'm there's
probably a resource out there I just
don't I don't necessarily know about it
but I assume there's a resource out
there that will teach you techniques for
problem solving like how do you actually
approach an algorithm that you never saw
before like a challenge you know you
know what steps do you take to break
that down and to solve it faster I know
that that exists I've I've read articles
about stuff like that before I don't
know a really good book about that to
recommend to you but hopefully maybe
somebody else in the in the live chat
has mentioned something okay there's a
good conversation here about different
languages for beginners and things so
I'm kind of skipping over it though but
it seems like the basic consensus is you
know lower-level languages are nice to
start out and teach you basic concepts
and then you can move on the
higher-level languages and they feel
easy that's kind of my thing like when
you look at a language like C um you
really like start to appreciate some of
the things that are just done for you
and like JavaScript like I don't have to
like say what kind of variable this is
you know I can just say it's a variable
and it just happens like I don't have to
declare that I know it's a string or you
know it's all the different I mean C
even have to they're like several
different types if you want to use an
that's bigger I think they call it a
double I don't remember for sure but I I
agree with that definitely you will
appreciate more kind of Modern Languages
if you do learn some of the older ones
shawn recommends python for beginners
yeah I've done some stuff with Python
it's really cool because there's not
like it's a lot with indentation and not
necessarily like semicolons so that's
kind of it was kind of fun
Python syntax is like so easy to type I
was able to do Python algorithm
challenges on my phone on the regular
keyboard it wasn't annoying because I
didn't have to add all these special
characters that I would normally have to
add like let's say if I were doing
JavaScript so I thought that was really
cool okay I'm getting towards the end of
the live chat
you go there's a lot of chat about how I
couldn't get the command to work for
less and so I'm kind of skipping through
that
okay Patrick says you can change the
health checks to hit the node server
port so that's cool it looks like I
won't have to do that but that's
actually good to know that that feature
is is available beau soon
it's a BOS un so sorry if i mispronounce
that let me know if if i did and how to
pronounce it correctly and i will
pronounce it correctly next time but
bosun says nice to be part of this
really very insightful discussions on
here yeah I feel like in this stream it
wasn't so much me giving anything
helpful but the live chat was just super
helpful so if you are watching later on
and you don't really have access to the
live chat sorry about that I'm trying to
read off as much as I can from the live
chat so you can you know get something
out of that but yeah it's just you you
all have been amazing in the live chat
I'm definitely gonna you know save this
chat and reference it in the future
Rohan asks no questions will what's your
handle on Twitter I'd love to follow you
it's it's just it's Jessie or Weibull so
J esse or the VI GTL and I just looked
down two lines and some someone already
put it in there so if you've watched any
of my other streams you know that I
frequently do that I don't read down
farther and I answer a question that's
already been answered so I also link to
my Twitter in the description for the
video so it's there if you don't have to
type it in you can link right right
there to my Twitter account I have my
own YouTube channel as well and there's
a link to that and I have my other
social media stuff linked from there so
if you care to follow me on any other
stuff social media you can I'm on like
most of the main social media things but
I'm primarily active on you know YouTube
Twitter and I do some Instagram stuff
too but not really a lot of code I just
like take pictures of the food that I
cook and put it up there occasionally I
do some kind of stuff but that's pretty
much it you're free to you know follow
me on LinkedIn too if you want for
connections but I don't other than for
networking I don't I'm not really on
there that often and I'm not on yeah I'm
like on most of the other networks but I
don't really do anything with them
[Music]
all right cool Thor it looks like a Thor
fall of me so everybody who's following
me on either my my youtube channel or
Twitter or anything else thank you
thanks for following I don't I don't get
any money off of subscribers or
followers or anything like that but I
just really appreciate that you know you
care enough to want to know what's you
know when I'm streaming and what's going
on and that and you've been helping me
out so I really appreciate that
Alberto says I'm in an HR office that is
more like a sports club with the
atmosphere my co-workers before prefer I
miss my cave yeah I understand that when
I'm I am it I'm at home today so it's a
different atmosphere than I'm used to
and actually my wife took the kids to
their grandparents house and she took
one of my daughters out to lunch with
their and the other ones with their
grandparents so normally my house would
be super noisy except for kids and
they're all under 8 years old but right
now it's actually pretty quiet other
than the lawn mowers and but when I am
at work I just like lock myself in my
office and my co-workers call it the
cave I keep the lights out and I stay I
stay locked in with headphones on so I'm
not anti-social I just get a lot more
done without interruptions so ha ha ha
okay so the the person that I said say
my name is cue cue knocks ok so I don't
even remember how I pronounced it but
the name is cue knocks so I will do my
best to try to remember that and
pronounce it correctly cue knocks that
definitely makes more sense than what I
was trying to say so
thanks for let me know how to pronounce
that if I ever mispronounce anybody's
name on here let me know I don't want to
I don't want to be mispronouncing your
name Patrick said dinner bell just rang
thanks for the stream Jesse you'll be
back tomorrow all right
yeah awesome thanks for watching Patrick
and for hanging in here for you know it
was ended up being a really long stream
Hugo says you can use get hooks so I
think that's probably in response to me
talking about ways to push code to to
multiple droplets multiple servers so I
have I've read a little bit about get
hooks but I haven't I haven't been too
successful with
so maybe I'm gonna have to read some
more some more about that Sean asked any
good list of programming problems to try
in any language hmm actually I I can't
remember offhand what I've seen but I
definitely have seen some websites that
have programming problems like there's a
site called hacker rank that does a lot
of like programming competitions I
subscribe to a newsletter that gives me
a new programming algorithm like I don't
know if it's once a week or once a day
or something but maybe oh maybe I'll do
a video about that that sounds like a
really good topic so I'm gonna make a
note about that actually right now I
keep a I keep a list of topics that you
all have either requested or I kind of
notice that a lot of people ask about in
the live chat to do videos on so I hope
to be doing some videos and putting them
on my youtube channel very soon so I
will add that to the list because that
sounds like a really useful a useful
thing to maybe highlight some some
places with good resources good
challenges to code in different
languages not just specifically for you
know JavaScript or something like that
okay all right let me get through almost
to the very end here of the live chat
queue Knox says you can use a script
that SSH into all servers and pools and
restarts not best practice but a good
start
okay that's yeah I had never thought
about that but you're right
yeah that that might be a good like kind
of thing to use before I can really
figure out what I you know how how I
want to do like a more permanent you
know solution so okay Thor says ansible
can do that okay yeah I noticed
Patrick did mention Hansel boy I forgot
to say that so I've no I haven't done
anything with ansible other than I I
know that I've heard the name before but
I haven't done anything with that so
I'll have to check that out let's see in
response to Shawn's question about list
of programming problems
Thor recommends exorcism dot exes yes at
exorcism I oh yeah for some reason that
it looked weird to me like it was
spelled differently but I think it's
exorcisms I uh so that's a funny name
but or advent of code Thor says advent
of code is for more advanced things but
it has a nice story around it
hey Thor says ansible is actually really
easy to set up and fast so maybe I will
have to give that give that a look oh
yeah cue knock says I can do it by it
via a stream and and you all can help me
I didn't think about that but that's
that actually that would make for a good
stream and I would appreciate the help
so maybe I'll have to off to remember
that when when I do try to set up
something there to to update or some
type of continuous integration thing
I'll stream it Chad says hey everyone
Chad's coming in at the end there nice
to have you here sorry that you missed
most of it the recording is going to be
available just a few minutes after I am
the stream so you can check that out
it's it's pretty long you can probably
skip through a lot of the beginning I'm
gonna have to maybe I can cut out the
beginning or at least put like a
timestamp somewhere in the descriptions
people can skip that because I always
have a lot of issues with my streaming
at the beginning
oh cool Thor Thor just follow it follows
me everywhere so awesome
Rowan followed as well
okay Rohan says hacker rank is good and
project Euler out of EUL er I don't know
exactly I say that are great actually I
did hear project Euler right I've heard
of that before
I'll have to check it out again because
I can't remember what exactly it was
like but I now that I see it I remember
that there's also a subreddit but Rohan
says there's also separated don't know
how active it is okay and last comment
oh now it's not the last one I had one
more one more sneaked in there but I
can't we still have 27 viewers even
after after this kind of epic length
stream here even going for almost two
and a half hours so for all of you
27 viewers thanks for sticking around
for this long so Hugo says for computer
programming challenges project Euler is
good and then URI online judge I've
never heard of that one so can check
that oh it's pronounced Euler I guess I
guess it's German oh okay oh yeah okay
cool yeah I'm not my German
pronunciation is not super great I
didn't realize those German word my last
name is German so I know how to
pronounce that but um other than that
I'm not I did attempt to learn German at
one time but I always try to learn Lang
speaking language like you know French
or you know Italian in German or
something and I never get past like the
basics so Oh awesome
Thor is from from Germany so cool yeah
my my ancestors at some point were from
Germany but they they moved to the
United States before it was the actually
called the United States
they've been over here for for a long
time so that's cool though I like that
people from all over the world watch
this I think that's that's really
awesome alright so that's it that's the
end of the the live chat so hopefully I
covered every all the questions and I'll
be back tomorrow I'll probably be
streaming from home again so hopefully I
won't have the same technical issues and
maybe I can do some testing earlier on
and get that all worked out
but I really appreciate all the help you
gave me this has been amazing I it would
have taken me so much longer to get
through all this without you so it
already took longer than I thought it
would but it really would have I
probably would have been lost at some
point so thank you so much and I hope
you all got something out of this as
well and forces thanks to the stream
you're welcome
and yeah so everybody thanks for
watching and I'll be back tomorrow at 2
p.m. eastern time I'll be streaming
again and we'll be setting up the the
SSL to work and actually making this
load balancer go live on on the real
live site so let me I can't find the
window to stop the stream I have too
many windows open haha so have a great
day and it looks there people still
going on the on the live chat so I don't
know how long the live chat stays open
but for as long as it stays open feel
free to keep keep it up and talk to each
other but I really appreciate everybody
watching I'll be back tomorrow have a
great day thanks